make way for Jalen Rose and the
mothership he can be seen on ESPN NBA
countdown pregame halftime show every
Friday leading into ESPN NBA game
telecast and he joins us on the program
Jay how are you today
always appreciate being going with the
legend and also acknowledging they could
check me out at 2:00 p.m. Eastern every
day on Jalen and Jacoby and countdown
this Friday Saturday and Sunday then you
know wow force don't sleep I like that
you know this is what I you're sort of
the James Brown of the NBA NBA TV
hardest-working man absolutely I take
pride in it I appreciate the multiple
opportunities I've been given
I've actually been covering the NBA on
television that I was in the league
starting in 2002 which means about 19
seasons covering NBA Finals if it wasn't
Michigan where were you going to go to
so I took a couple of visits usually as
a high school player um
you see where people that you looked up
to or from your hometown had success and
you ended up wanting to go there so a
lot of people don't know the UNLV team
led by Larry Johnson Greg Anthony and
Stacey Augmon
the year they won the championship the
Final Four MVP with Anderson honey he
attended my high school Detroit
southwestern so I always loved UNLV
Steve Smith now doing a terrific job on
television went to Michigan State
Magic Johnson another big guard that I
idolized so I took a visit to Michigan
State
sherry chuse Derrick Coleman like my big
brother Dave Bing is my godfather took
Envisat to Syracuse ultimately I
couldn't turn down the opportunity to be
the fifth member of the five five which
is why I changed my number from number
42 in high school to five when I got to
college I saw this quote from you and I
think you said it too greeny on get up
that you think James Harden could get 90
in a game and before we get to that
possibility I started to wonder are you
hoping he gets to 90 or at least 82 so
we don't have to keep mentioning Kobe
got 81
on the Raptors team that you played for
not at all see one thing about being a
public figure for as long as I have and
we have the public is going to find
things to bring up about your career
things that you said been in the wrong
place in the wrong time that's going to
happen James Harden scoring 90 doesn't
take away people when they get a chance
to try to tease me about Kobe scoring 81
here's why people that played against
wilt when he scored 100 hopefully some
of them are still alive they may or may
not be for example somebody like Devin
Booker when he scores 70 points on a
Boston Celtics team we don't brag about
those guys you know why because they're
not as famous as me and if that's the 1l
I take for public consumption I'm with
it because he is one of the top seven to
eight players to ever do it
I look at Harden I'm fascinated I don't
know if we appreciate it I don't I know
a lot of people don't like that style
though Jalen but I I watch Harden and
everybody knows he's going to shoot and
four he's still able to do what he wants
to do when he wants to do it and he
still hasn't gotten really hot in a game
yet this year that's why I said that
he's going to score 90 eventually
because for those of us who intimately
watch these games
he actually goes for it on a nightly
basis he's just not being efficient
Reggie Miller one of the greatest
three-point shooters of all time
probably took 15 or 16 threes in a game
once James Harden averages that on a
nightly basis so on a night when he's
getting to the line making his threes
and actually efficient for two or as the
chief pushing 70 or 80 just like that so
that's where I came with that man we've
talked a lot about Luca done shake this
second year and if you were gonna
describe his game to somebody who hadn't
seen Luca Danxia how would you describe
easy work and that's the best compliment
you could give somebody out there you
notice he doesn't seem like he's ever
out of control he's not sped up he's not
bothered by the competition he is a
fierce competitor
he has all of the skills dribble pass is
shoot dribble shoot from range and also
he's a versatile guy that could get you
boards that can make teammates around
them better
I like his core personality he's a fun
player to watch and I appreciate
watching math games like while he's out
there ballin only class also we love a
good story the media loves a good story
you know I mentioned this yesterday
Yanis one is MVP Harden got his MVP we
tend to look for the new story LeBron is
sort of reinvented himself that's a new
story and they're playing extremely well
the chances of dhansak winning the MVP
this year are what what would it hinge
on it would hinge on being behind the
Brawn being behind Yanis being behind
harden because a lot of that too has to
do with your team's success and I don't
anticipate the math being one of the top
handful of teams in the Western
Conference
even though russell westbrook did win
MVP and his team was a six seed but
that's when he first averaged a
triple-double this just won't be his
year for it to happen but that doesn't
mean over the next couple of seasons he
won't be in position to do it Yanis is
top three in the league right now in
points and rebounds and yet 15 assists
last night so he's not slowing down at
all yeah but it's weird how we do love
the new story though Jalen yes we do
love the new story but that's the great
thing about today's NBA now teams and
fans can look at your squad it has some
sort of optimism even if they're not
contenders and young players like Luca
Dodgers they'll help make that happen
when you start to look at the Clippers
game plan here how does this backfire on
them
you mean as far as Lowell management
yeah I didn't want to use load
management I figured game plan okay got
it got it that's right we go we're gonna
try to eliminate little management at
rest on the box scores I'd like to okay
I'd like okay okay here's how it's going
to backfire the two best teams the
Lakers and the Clippers in the West will
not face each other in the Western
Conference Finals
because Kawhi Leonard and possibly Paul
George are going to miss so many
regular-season games is going to put the
Clippers
position to be like a third or fourth
seat so now those two teams might end up
playing in the second round as opposed
to the Western Conference Finals okay
yeah I'm still I you know I usually wait
until after Christmas before I get a
better handle on these teams and I don't
know if I'm gonna get a good handle on
the Clippers and say okay now I know who
they are and and I know I was told
yesterday by a source that there's
nothing wrong with Kauai this is just
the game plan he's gonna play 60 games
the Clippers knew that to start the
season do you think there's any you know
aftershocks with with the knee injury do
you think that's something that could be
still lingering there for Kawhi Leonard
this season so I believe that last year
you know coming two seasons ago he
played nine games so last year having
wood Adam Silver term recovery days and
I appreciated that term because when you
have an injury the way he did he
deserves an opportunity to ease himself
back in the NBA action but he was in the
East last year and he joined a Raptors
team that was always flirting with the
number one or two seed the last three or
four years even before he arrived so
they were 17 and four without him and
now you graduate that same theory to the
Western Conference is just different
competition from top to bottom the thing
that if the league is going to have to
try to figure out there is there is it
motivation now for current players to
want to play all 82 games it used to be
a badge of honor to show up at your job
every night and usually the best players
around the game set that tone so when I
first came in the league players like
Michael Jordan Hakeem Olajuwon Reggie
Miller Stockton and Malone they showed
up to play every night so that became
something that players strive to do now
and I blame the media and the fans a
little bit on this because when you
start to dumb down everybody's
achievement to only reen county and all
of a sudden the player like kawaki say
all you're going to do is judge me about
how many rings I win and so I'm going to
not focus on a Wednesday night game in
November you guys are going to pay
attention to what I do and the playoffs
and that's what leads to a guy like the
Arlena Cleveland to go to Miami to get a
couple of rings and then when he get his
ring guess what he does he leaves again
this is like Kevin Durant leaves OKC
goes to the Warriors went to rings seems
to be unhappier in Golden State and he
was with the Oklahoma City Thunder then
he leaves there and goes to the net so
that has created a climate that now
players don't value the regular season
as much as they should and that's
unfortunate it's great to talk to you
Jay have a good weekend we appreciate
your time as always thanks for the love
I appreciate you that's Jalen Rose
espn/abc NBA analyst for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]